hey guys it's Max Vine and I'm Ben Ben
is the newest member of our team here at
Max Tech so make sure to give him some
love down in the comments Welcome to our
special New York City edition of our
camera comparison where we're going to
see if a $1,200 iPhone 15 Pro Max can
compete with this Pro camera setup
that's worth over
$5,000 so we went on an awesome New York
City trip and I took a bunch of photos
with both of these cameras and neither
Max or Ben has seen them so they're
going to vote on which one is better and
you guys can do the same using a pen and
paper now the first thing that I noticed
is the dynamic range is not as good on
the right side photo it's also a little
bit less sharp but I do like the colors
a little bit more but if I had to choose
it would be the left one I also agree so
the lighting looks more natural to me on
this left photo uh with the dynamic
range the sky is not blown out like on
the right picture all right let's see
what this is by the way this is in
Central Park it's my wife at the little
castle I oh yep that's the iPhone on the
left does a better job and I know it's
stacking a ton of images for that
dynamic range really good next up we
have you and your wife in this picture
right here I do like that it's warm and
the faces do look more natural to me and
it just overall looks better to me yeah
I would say that that photo right there
has too much saturation and warmth
compared to real life because I was
there but I would still choose it for uh
my camera roll that's the Sony wow okay
next up we have a zoom shot oh okay this
is actually comparing kind of like 5x
zoom and it was snowing a little bit in
New York believe it or not it was
snowing so there's a little bit of snow
texture there yeah I will say that these
are so close and the crazy thing is the
a7r is what 64 megapixel I think it's 6
60 compared to 5x is 12 so that's crazy
I'm having a hard time so difference I
do see is the tree right here here it's
actually it's not in Focus this looks a
little crunchy I think I'll go with the
left one that's the Sony it's actually
70 mm which is the most this lens can do
it's a 24 to 70 it can't do 120 like the
iPhone can so I actually had to crop in
a little bit more and post next up oh I
just saw this really cool slammed car
street sweeper so the first thing I do
see is that the background is blurred
out I do like that better than the on
the left and I noticed the highlights
are blown out here whereas here it's all
kept now in reality my eyes saw this
glare that was there super bright but I
think I might still choose this picture
this looks nice and sharp it just looks
more natural yep that's the Sony okay
which it does have the extra blur which
you couldn't do portrait mode on the
iPhone because it was too far away with
the 2x so next up this is the view from
our hotel basically all just Windows a
lot of buildings there could didn't see
nothing
I do like the natural look over here
where you can actually see the building
versus here it's kind of blown out you
do have more uh contrast contrast and
you got more detail here yeah so which
one are you going to
choose well probably this one right here
the right one I'll go for the left we'll
disagree right iPhone on the right Sony
on the left wow now to make my iPhone
more like a pro camera I actually
brought the insta 360 flow which is the
best Gamal for iPhone 15 Pro with smooth
AI tracking giving my Boll shots super
smooth professional stabilization that
you simply can't replicate by using your
iPhone handheld it comes with a Smart
Wheel that gives you loads of physical
controls like a joystick for smooth
panning and tons of controls to do
things like instantly switch from
landscape mode to portrait mode and
selfie mode for vlogging it comes with a
ton of AI tracking features with gesture
support Zoom control facial tracking
with deep track 3.0 which can track you
and move the the gimbal as you walk
around even reidentifying you when you
leave and come back into frame but the
best part is that it folds down into a
super compact design which was easy to
fit into my luggage as well as carry
around New York City in my coat pocket
so if you really want to turn your
iPhone into a pro camera check out the
insta 360 Flow by using the link in the
video description to be one of the first
20 orders to get their special holiday
deal where you get a 12% discount one
free Spotlight and a free t-shirt all
right we have my wife here at some
random Park doing portrait mode I think
this is also 2x portrait yeah this has
more blur that's for sure now comparing
the cutouts both look really good and
obviously one of these is fake but it's
hard to tell they both good I think we
know which one is fake I think the right
one's fake really what do you think the
left one's fake thought it was this one
okay oh man so which one would we choose
getting
close I would choose this one I'm going
to choose the right one too this one
looks a little bit maybe crunchy if that
dude if that's an iPhone I will be
impressed let's see show us it's the
Sony yeah if you look super close you
could see little tiny hairs with like
Supernatural blurs so yeah there you go
oh got this cool kind of mural that was
mural whatever it's called This is a
zoom shot I'm going to go for the one on
the right little more natural little
more detail mhm picture looks greater on
that one right that's the Sony again so
I actually took a 2x on each so that's
48 on the Sony and I kind of cropped in
more but yeah this really good all right
got a detail shot I believe this is
comparing 48 megapixel on the iPhone
compared to the 60 jeez both did so good
what looks better I prefer the one on
the right the background blur is more
natural versus the one on the left it
kind of you can see the background still
yeah that is
true as far as detail I mean both of
them are so close might even be more
detail on this one it's probably just
more sharpening but I would take this
one that's the Sony oo Sony all right
here we go this is a far Zoom shot I
think it's 5x I would definitely take
the one on the left this one looks too
cool this looks a little crunchy
compared to this looks super natural I
agree the one on the left exactly yep
that's the Sony I guess the iPhone kind
of messed with all the colors what it's
too much processing which can happen
sometimes cuz there so much going on
compared to one shot this is the Grand
Central Station terminal awesome place
first thing I noticed is that the bow is
actually sharper on this image I'm going
to actually choose the one on the left
just cuz this pops more even though it's
darker and might be a little too dark
but this one pops more for me iPhone on
the left son on the right all right this
is inside take a look at this what's
better here so I like the one on the
right better but I actually don't
know this really pops here yeah the
colors all kept dynamic range is good
where here it's kind of going away now I
do notice maybe a little bit too much
processing and sharpening here but I'll
still stick with this image I think what
about same here it just looks better
overall that's the iPhone surprisingly
finally man that's a big crop too a big
CR yeah I cropped in a ton that's still
impressive though yeah very impressive
all right this is the uh metro subway
station looks really cool the picture I
do like is the one on the right looks
better to me mhm I vote for the one on
the left I feel like it looks more
magical this one everything is in Focus
you see a lot more stuff everywhere um
compared to here your main focus is more
towards the center you have a nice blur
right here and even though technically
it might have less visible sharpening or
detail I like it better yep that one is
the Sony and the crazy thing is we are
looking on a 16-in screen if you have
this on a larger display it might be a
bigger difference mhm we have the Apple
Store in the Grand Central Station was
probably the craziest Apple Store I've
seen they took over just the top balcony
nuts I like the image on the left a lot
more I like all the detail you see on
this railing just in general the detail
across and you have better dynamic range
here the saturation here I feel like is
too high the whole Ambience is just
caught a little bit better I think the
right picture looks better cuz you can
see the face in the detail right here
with that person it's it's more natural
you guys let us know your thoughts down
below Sony on the
right one really cool thing I saw with
this one with the iPhone is that all of
these lights really pop and shine where
on here it kind of du them all out um so
I yeah I like that okay and this is a
really cool kind of shot showing the
crazy high ceilings here is this a
portrait or is it a regular shot this is
a portrait yep on the iPhone and on both
it's hard to know which one's the iPhone
cuz they're both natural looking there's
no overly fake blur that like you get
with some Android phones ker job I like
the shot on the left I like the one on
the right to me I like warmer pictures
and that just looks better to me oh
iPhone on left Sony on right oh cyber
truck we actually saw it guys yeah it
was so cool here it is from the back and
you got some nice kind of scenes in the
street outside oh just awesome vny I
hope we don't disagree on this image
we've been disagreeing but I hope on
this one we don't that's supposed to be
red right yes on this picture o so I do
like that one on the right that pops so
much right there so much better it does
and if you look at the sky beautiful
compared to here now the dynamic range
difference was huge cuz we're inside
it's super bright Sunset outside the
lights of the street and everything
looks better in this image absolutely
that's the iPhone honestly like the the
Sony camera just couldn't get it right
in order to expose properly it had to
blow out the sun yeah and you couldn't
recover it right the highlights and
these are raw shots by the way and if I
recover it it actually brought down the
light strip I tried so yeah and here you
are had to get a shot like this yeah man
automatically the one on the right for
me cuz you can still see the car details
versus here it's blown out completely it
just kind of takes away from you guys
yeah I feel like we might be brought up
a little bit too much here compared to
the shadowing but I would take the shot
on the right that's the iPhone again
just that Dynamic smart HDR 5 is just
nuts does a good job huge Improvement
okay now this is in Central Park wipes
with some coffee man the detail here in
the hair to me I like that a lot better
the overall color I like better I have
to agree on that one too it it looks
more natural on this one that's the Sony
Sony did a killer job whereas this is
kind of like flat for a little too much
HDR probably probably yeah okay we got a
who is this Columbus something I don't
know with that crazy like $2.5 million
Penthouse at the top there insane you
mean 250 million oh 250 okay yeah 250
million yeah the crazy thing is just how
close yeah have to pixel like dude this
this camera is expensive man and it's
not fun lugging a camera like this with
a massive lens around I actually left it
at the hotel one time because it was
annoying to carry with the strap on my
neck it was yeah it was bad man this is
so hard but I do like how we have the
clouds standing out a little bit more
while this isn't as dark I'm going with
the right then I have to
right that's the iPhone 15 Pro Max can't
believe you guys chose that that's crazy
so much easier just to have this but you
have it in your pocket already and the
blur killed it everywhere the edges oh
we got Mewtwo Mewtwo this is right next
to yeah I think it's Mewtwo it's right
next to the uh Tesla showroom this one
was hard yeah sorry this one looks
identical to me yeah it's so close in
terms of
detail um insane but I think I like this
one a little bit more warm it's a little
bit more even with the lighting I vote
for the left one I agree that's the Sony
Sony Sony again nice and natural all
right Central Park again this cool
whatever it is I do like the details on
the right you can see their faces more
clearly yeah even though it's compressed
small but looking at this the sky is
blown out which sucks yeah so here you
can make this a little warmer which I
like the warmer color even though it was
pretty uh dark and we had some sunlight
here so it's a very tough shot um but
I'll take the left left is the I better
HDR and yeah yeah for this shot you'd
have to take multiples and then combine
them because of how much brighter that
was this is inside the uh one World
Trade Center this really cool hallway to
me I definitely like the right one
better because of the lighting even
though this has a greater difference in
um shadowing and stuff this is even adds
to that tunnel effect and wear a little
bit brighter too so I'll would take the
right one I do like the one on the right
just has more details yep that is the
Sony definitely the iPhone crushed the
blacks because to my eyes it was not
that black so yeah and it brought all
this down yeah it's a tough one because
the background is just so white super
bright and you guys are a little dark
like dressed in all black yeah it makes
it hard all right we got another one
here this is under I don't know some
kind of bridge yeah no this
is no the Central Park whatever thing
okay walkway this is the Bethesda
pool um that's what it is I love the one
on the right I love that the sun stands
out a lot the warmth the sun was in my
eyes this is too cool and it just
doesn't have that magic I'd have to
agree on that one that's the iPhone no
matter what I did I could not get this
to glow like that well if you bring it
down it's just gone it's not nine images
stack together and what I'm surprised by
is the iPhone did not over HDR this it
left the brighter highlights in the
darkness this is the other side of the
one where World Trade Center this
awesome designed building so this one's
really tough for me they both honestly
look identical to me one might have a
little more sharpening here but they
both look good I'd probably choose the
one on the left it just kind of speaks
to me a little more yeah so here where I
look my eyes instantly first go to the
top and then I can kind of look around
at the detail and the motion here it's
all very even and it makes it harder to
know where to look do you look down here
do you look up so I like the left yep
that's the iPhone definitely pops more
yeah that's it did a really good job
with HDR not overdoing it okay this is
in uh Brighton Beach on the streets so
this a portrait shot I assume y on both
yep so it's a portrait it was actually
really dark here we have the boka balls
that are popping more so than that one
the edging looks really good on both
images so the first thing I noticed is
that the background on this is not as
blurry as the one on the right so as a
portrait I would definitely like the one
on the right I agree too um I like that
she stands out where here the opposite
of the other one my eyes also kind of
don't know where to look it's more even
where this you have a pop on the subject
definitely right that's the iPhone
iPhone the iPhone the blur looks so
natural it's insane it's incredible huh
did a killer job I think this was
actually a uh night mode portrait so it
actually took a couple seconds yeah all
right this is from the One World
Observatory from the very top tallest
building in USA yeah we were like almost
1,00 ft up through glass taking this
picture it was amazing and that's the uh
Statue of Liberty so to me I'd rather
have this one in my camera roll because
of the orange Sky it's actually my
favorite color beautiful oh really nice
and we also have more definition here um
better HDR while we have Darkness here
yeah the left that's the iPhone 120 mm Y
and the issue I had with the right was
that I could Den noise but then it got
rid of all the detail so I had to have a
balance it was really dark it was
insanely dark yeah okay got a another
portrait here it is insane how close the
iPhone is to an over $55,000 setup
that's huge and it CES way more work I'm
going with the right one once again the
subjects are popping more we have
slightly more blur but that doesn't
matter the subjects matter so they're
right I agree that's the iPhone this is
convincing me not to take the pro camera
and I have like literally seven eight n
of them it was a pain to haul around
everywhere such a pain next up we went
to Starbucks Reserve guys it was so cool
there best cheesecake ever is this a 5x
or a 2X I think this might be a 2X with
a 48 equivalent on that camera but it's
crazy oh my goodness so on this one I'll
say that I think this is the Pro Camera
but this one looks
better that one looks better and the
blur is so realistic I could be wrong
actually but I'm voting for the left I'd
have to agree on this one it's the
iPhone guys crazy thing and this is a 2X
crop it's using a quarter of the
resolution man it's crazy how Apple has
made the bokeh so similar to a real
camera at the same Zoom they even
blurred out the front like raspberries
here because this was slightly behind it
just like this did yeah it's insane it's
nuts all right this was at STK in the
meat packing district and if I remember
it was really dark here too yeah it was
really dark it was hard especially with
the Bright Lights this is a tough one
because the background is blown out here
but the subject in the face looks more
natural on the one on the right what I'm
wondering is what color is your wife's
hair because we have some differences
for definitely not orange like
that there's benefits to both but I'm
going to vote for the one on the right
that's the iPhone told you y one tough
thing was with noise because if you
notice on these gloves there's some
noise yeah but if I got rid of the noise
then the the detail was gone as you can
see this is actually a little bit more
soft than the iPhone and this actually
has texture in her sweater or hoodie
where you don't have it here and the
crazy thing is we started out I was
getting almost all uh Pro Camera choices
until it started getting dark yep all
right got some very bright lights here
in Brighton Beach so the first thing I
notic is that the sign is actually
sharper and it just looks better to me
yeah this whole image looks a little bit
sharper at least over here I see maybe a
little bit better dynamic range on the
one on the left uh but I think I'd go
for the right one that's the Sony that
is the Sony yeah all right rooftop on
STK awesome bokeh here I do like the one
on the right Max and Alina do look
really nice on that one here it's very
blown out I don't know what's going on
but I bet you that's the iPhone camera
yeah I like that we have more detail
here the lighting how it's falling off I
like that the sky is darker almost
everything about this image is better
that's the iPhone the iPhone and with
this one it was hard because to my eyes
you guys were black like you couldn't
see anything because the trees behind
you yeah so I had to take it and then
bring you guys up and it was just a
crazy balance of noise reduction sharp
everything it was just yeah and plus the
iPhone might have taken three seconds
Blended 10 15 shots together compared to
one incredible all right same sort of
situation on Brighton Beach here so if
we're basing it off being in my camera
roll I definitely like the one on the
right it just to me looks more natural
yeah for sure the one on the right looks
better that's the Sony so the iPhone
messed up the white balance it butchered
it it was way too blue like terrible czy
it it was really like this yeah all
right so this is from The Observatory
again got a really nice Zoom shot here I
really like the one on the right um I
like that you see the walls of the
building where here kind of uh Blends
together so this just has more pop even
though here you still get the towers
here you see more and I actually like it
this time yeah this one has greater Det
detail for sure I like the one on the
right yep that's the iPhone all right
back on the beach man these are close I
know it was dark I have to go with the
left one really um I think so you have
the sky the little bit of sunset poking
through um in general detail even though
there's some parts of the image that's
better here I like the left one I would
have to go with the one on the right it
just looks better to me all right son
again okay okay this is kind of like a
zoom portrait left and right we know
which one is going on right here right
now yeah it's a little bit of a drawback
that you get van did you notice it yet
there you go boom that is clear iPhone
yep the iPhone is still plagued even
though daytime it got better I really
don't like those things even though this
image it kind of
matches it's hard because the rest of
this image is great this has more um
noise in it while having less detail at
the same time gosh I don't want to
choose this because of this but I might
have to I don't know you know what no
I'll still take the softer one with more
noise because of that I would go with
the iPhone even though this sucks there
you go guessed right those dots have
ruined enough of my shots where it goes
over somebody's face and other stuff
always all all right here we go nice
beautiful shot here it's hard this has
more detail but this you almost have
like a HDR kind of a look and look at
the artifact right there there did you
see that he artifa immediately the one
on the right it just looks so much CLE
we have the little
reflection over here got to have it this
has more real detail but this looks
better that looks way better that's the
iPhone once again that was about it's 2x
mode that was 2x but it is stacking
images crazy all right so they've just
tallied it up if you did it as well
tally up your scores what' you guys get
well I got 20 for the iPhone and 15 for
the Pro oh my goodness camera wow and I
just know especially if it's dark I'm
not taking one of my cameras out because
the new iPhone 15 does such a good job
with processing amazing and I got 19 for
the iPhone and 16 for the Pro Camera and
the crazy thing is we actually voted
against each other many times but the
end result is the same you guys let us
know what your tallies were and your
opinions were down in the comment
section below I can't wait to just go
and read through what you guys think
it's crazy so I guess that means uh
don't spend 5K on a pro camera yeah
honestly like I have yeah 7 eight or n
Pro cameras and the iPhone does so well
now and this fits in your pocket come on
that it's insane that's crazy apple good
job yeah thank you guys for watching um
say hi to Ben down below uh go and click
that Circle above to subscribe check out
one of those videos right over there and
we'll see you in the next
one